he is none other than former Denver
Bronco and former Michigan Wolverine
champion had half of his championship
stolen by the University of Nebraska
front Oman sang
he's Brian Griese how are you Brian how
is your mental health you know what
Brian I tweeted out during the game
Michigan Notre Dame game breaking news
that I began drinking that was around
that was right around the second quarter
right around dinnertime when my wife
took the three children out of the house
Brian does that does that give you an
indication well you have to have a
pregame you know ritual tailgate
something like that just to get you in
the right frame of mind for what's gonna
happen this year with Michigan so what
is gonna happen this year with Michigan
Brian so if you ask you marvel I think
he believes that this team could be a
good football team what we saw Saturday
night was was beyond that I think
everybody who's a Michigan fan wanted to
see improvement on the offense you bring
in Jim McElwain ed Warner the offensive
line coach you still have kept Hamilton
who was a coordinator for the Annapolis
Colts you got a lot of chiefs in the
kitchen there and it just it hasn't
worked offensive ly I still think that
this could be a good football team
defensively we know what they are with
Don Brown but to not score an offensive
touchdown through 58 minutes of the
opener it's just it's just not
acceptable
so to me rich they have to get better up
front the offensive line and develop
players they've signed great players but
they haven't developed them well enough
on the offensive line to be successful
with any kind of consistent well that's
the third rail conversation Brian is
that Jim Harbaugh is not the right man
for the job do you think he is you know
so far rich it hasn't been good and I'm
not gonna say that he's not the right
guy for the job going forward but it has
to get a lot better this year I think
that opening game created a sense of
urgency for the University of Michigan
football team and
horrible in particular to turn it around
this year and you know there's certainly
opportunities with you know Michigan
State Ohio State games coming up Penn
State to make this a successful year but
I just think that the first game and the
first taste in the mouth kind of
expedited this process what do you think
of what Brandon Edwards had to say Brian
it wasn't totally wrong I would not have
taken it out on the individual players
obviously but you know what Braylon
Edwards is saying has a has a bitter
truth to it which is why I think you see
the way Jim Harbaugh reacted to it Brian
Griese here on the Rich Eisen show so
clearly tool was the right choice right
and and so to me that's what Nick Saban
showed in barking at Maria Taylor and
her her appropriate question saying
you're trying to get me to say something
negative because her question is of what
did you learn from the quarterbacks and
we saw what we saw from TOA
how do you think this all plays out for
Alabama the rest of the season at the
quarterback position Brian well I think
you know what you've seen from from Nick
this week he's named two of the starter
and that it will use Jalen in certain
situations ie short yardage goal line
where he can run the football I think
that's what you're going to see for the
remainder of the season from from
Alabama and I think it's it's the right
decision from Nick Saban because to a
chunk of my lower opens up their offense
in in a myriad of different ways but you
know the question is the way that Nick
Saban handled that controversy through
the off season preseason first game and
then with Maria who you're right asked a
completely inbounds question and it's
kind of interesting to see that Nick
Saban who so many young coaches players
looked up to fall down in that moment
because and he would admit I think that
he fell down in that moment because so
many people look up to me you don't want
coaches to have to act like that
and
so hopefully he learns from it and
hopefully those watching understand that
you don't need to act like that to be a
head coach at any level Brian Griese
college football analyst for ESPN and
we'll get to Monday Night Football and
the NFL in a second so do you think that
quarterbacks who are get aget passed
over or or think they have an
opportunity to start that don't should
have free rein to transfer whenever they
want however they want in college
football Brian well rich you're asking a
guy that when I came to Michigan I was
sixth on the depth chart you know behind
guys like Todd Collins and Jay Riemersma
and Jason Carr and Scott left Lord you
know you got on and on and on and you
know I so I have a different take on it
I waited my time you never know what's
going to happen
with injuries and other kids that leave
I just I look back at what happened in
my career and if I had made a decision a
quick decision as a young immature 18 19
year old to leave and go to some other
school or a max school or Division two
or three school what I would have missed
out on and had I not stuck it out and I
think a lot of that comes from you know
our old friend Bo Schembechler who said
those who stay will be champions and I
still believe that in my heart and even
when you know the number one recruit in
the country Scott Dreisbach came in and
he started over me as a younger player
and then every recruited a guy from
California and may have heard of them
that's you know so I I would love to see
the epidemic of quarterback transfers in
college kind of subside a little bit cuz
I think it's gotten out of control
Brady was never above you on the death
chart though was he right no but we yeah
we competed he was two years younger
than me and my my fifth year he and I
were competing for the starting job so
did he have that competitive fire then
that is he's so famous for now Brian
yeah there's no question there's no
question Tommy you know and I in the
guise of us in the locker room when we
first met Tommy you know this kid that
came from California and he had he had
longer hair it wasn't quite down to his
shoulders but it definitely was longer
hair and you know we didn't know what we
were going to get in in Tom Brady but
certainly quickly you could see that
that there was just a different energy
and a different focus and intentionality
from Tom that quite frankly you knew he
was gonna be a success once he had the
opportunity you know we talked about it
the other day with Ty Law Brian Griese
that it's amazing that a few years later
in the National Football League on a
snowy night in New England that Brady
and Charles Woodson of all people would
meet in the backfield for one of the
most famous playoff moments of all time
the Raiders call it the Tuck rule game
the Patriots call it the snow game where
do you stand on that subject
Brian fumble not where do you stand on
this subject as I was watching the game
rich you know so I'm a little bit torn
Who am I gonna root for him I got root
for my former teammate Tom or my former
teammate Charles right and so you know I
had to make a quick decision before the
game started and given that I was
playing for the Broncos at that time I
clearly had to go against the Raiders
and so I was okay I love that
so you went AFC West right there and in
that regard Brian as somebody who
stepped right into the shoes that John
Elway vacated you were the first starter
after the Duke left after two Super Bowl
wins what advice do you give Case Keenum
who's now the Dukes hope to be the next
Elway cuz we're just throwing Peyton
Manning's experience in Denver out the
window because they all knew that he was
just gonna be their first short period
of time hoping to catch Superbowl
lightning in a bottle what advice would
you give Case Keenum in the Rocky
Mountains Brian Griese you know I think
it's you were in a glass bubble and you
just got to keep the blinders on and
there's going to be some ups and downs
as the season goes they have gotten
better I believe offensively up front on
the offensive line but they're still
going to be some some bumps in the
there's going to be opinions unlike
anything he's ever experienced good and
bad his relationship with John Elway I
think is solid I think John and I spoke
with John
during these preseason games that I was
announcing on television and John
actually told me that they were very
close to to getting a trade done for
Case Keenum when he was in LA with the
Rams and just weren't able to get it
done so John has had an affection for
her case and his abilities for for quite
some time and I know he was excited to
get him from Minnesota so I think you
know John has a belief in case and and
so that that goes a long way to
mitigating some of the ups and downs
that that case will inevitably go
through this year but I think case is
going to be fine and honestly rich after
doing for their preseason games yep
I think this offense will surprise some
people it was it was an abomination last
year but they have added two outstanding
talents at the receiver position at
Cortland Sutton and Deshawn Hamilton and
they get back the return of Jake but
from injury your favorite Michigan tight
em so I think they're gonna be much
better offensively this year well I mean
it's starting tires from the Ohio State
right heuerman that that kid can ball
out Bryan right he can he can play he's
just been hurt and he hasn't been
consistent and he's dealt with knee
injury after knee injuries if he can
stay healthy you know so a couple more
minutes left here with Brian Griese
you're calling the first Monday night
game of the season coming up on Monday
between the Jets and the Lions Sam's
Arnold youngest Super Bowl era week one
starter period nobody's ever been as
young as Sam darn 'old how do you think
he is going to fare and with the Jets
putting all the eggs in his basket right
from the get-go here
I felt Sam Donald was of the five guys
drafted in the first round at
quarterback this year I felt like he had
the the best head on his shoulders
not just from a from a smart standpoint
but but also from a from a from a
standpoint where he could handle the
pressure and I think that he's got
enough pieces around him with Josh
McCown obviously I think as a veteran
quarterback to help him with kind of the
ups and downs but he's also very
confident and and he's won the locker
room this job was not given to him by
Todd Bowles he had to go out there and
he had to perform better than Teddy
Bridgewater and he had to win the
confidence of the team I think he did
that certainly there's a rookie
quarterback there's gonna be ups and
downs but but he has a unique skillset
and a unique temperament that I think
this is the right decision for the Jets
and the organization moving forward and
then the lines what have you seen
already on tape film whatever for a team
that now has a new coach we're all
taught we're basically talking about
every other team in the NFC North right
now because the Bears are who we think
they might be to use a Denny Green
phrase with Khaleel Mac now coming
they're taking on Aaron Rodgers in the
first Sunday night game of the year
Rodgers getting paid like that and the
Packers now have him back healthy and
the Vikings get Kirk Cousins we all
think that their Super Bowl worthy who
are the Lions best you can tell I don't
think anybody knows rich and I think
we're not gonna find out until until we
play these first couple of games because
Matt Patricia first-time head coach and
who spent the past 13 years with the
Patriots under Bill Belichick is really
the only guy he's ever had as a mentor
how is he gonna be is he gonna be able
to win this team over are they buying
into what he's selling one of the things
I'm really interested to see and I want
to talk with Matt Patricia later this
week is after 13 years of watching the
relationship between Bill Belichick and
Tom Brady is he going to try to
establish that same
kind of relationship with Matt Stafford
in his tenth year because we know that
Matt Stafford is talented and can
shoulder the load so in that the kind of
relationship is that the structure that
Matt Patricia is trying to put into
place I think it'll be fascinating to
watch and certainly nobody has taken
alliance seriously and I think they have
some pieces to compete in that division
now I know you've got interviews to
conduct and practices to watch but are
you gonna sneak up to Ann Arbor next
weekend this coming weekend I think I'm
so is everything going to be all right
there Bryan um you know on behalf of
Wolverine nation wondering if from a guy
that's gotten a ring with Lloyd Carr
he's everything going to be all right
there everything's gonna be fine
you think I'll patronize me Brian Griese
come on seriously paper bag it'll be
okay paper bag to breathe in not put on
my head right correct okay good chat
Brian always enjoy it let's do this
again thanks man I really appreciate
enjoy the first week of the season pal
sure will I'm loving it already thanks
to the call at Brian Griese on Twitter
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience